han conseguido lo que muchos creían
imposible ascender el k2 en pleno
invierno
el equipo de 10 alpinistas nepalíes
alcanzó los 8.611 metros de esta montaña
el sábado marcando un nuevo récord
mundial conocida como la montaña salvaje
el k2 se encuentra a lo largo de la
frontera entre china y pakistán y es la
segunda cima más alta del mundo
el equipo de sherpas aprovechó una
ventana de buen clima con temperaturas
de 50 grados bajo cero para seguir
adelante fue un momento de orgullo
paranormal pour ya uno de los alpinistas
estamos orgullosos de formar parte de la
historia de la humanidad y mostrar que
la colaboración el trabajo en equipo y
una actitud mental positiva pueden
llevar los límites hacia todo lo que
creamos posible anteriormente por ya
había escalado todas las 14 montañas de
más de 8000 metros en tan solo 6 meses y
sin oxígeno suplementario pero el k2
está considerada como la montaña más
desafiante de todas este invierno
decenas de alpinistas se embarcaron en
un peligroso viaje esperando alcanzar la
misma proeza el sábado el montañista
español sergi mingote murió después de
sufrir una caída mientras descendía ha
habido 450 intentos de alcanzar la cima
de esta montaña pero sólo durante el
verano menos de 300 acabaron con éxito
en un terreno dominado por alpinistas
occidentales
los sherpas locales fueron vistos
durante mucho tiempo como aquellos que
ayudaban a que otros alcanzaran el éxito
el ascenso de este equipo ha sido
descrito como un día histórico para el
país y para el montañismo nepalí